welcome to this video on playing
international master super Sasha from
Israel mark back which yes I played him
before number of times Oh only open only
once according to the statistics here
with win I thought I played more keep
going check to play my pet line
that sounds slightly uncommon for der
can you go you for you may be
immediately I better came I can just
play like like normally in transposing
now it's taking some time for this some
relatively a normal position 98 here
some mandatory almost Bishop g5 is a big
threat what that's strange okay
okay yeah this is the kind of this the
kind of stuff where you feel really bad
if you don't win the game because that's
in every beginners book on the name zone
that you must play 98 to prevent Bishop
g5 so it's really bitter yeah it's like
a quite provoking to not play out yet
it's difficult would like to go without
g5 now and you really don't want to play
g5 without with a que on g8 you know
here I go fr I think or let's let's look
at this many many good good ways to play
him
now care for a force perfectly okay just
am trying to break through here
immediately
okay so e5 right what are you doing
against that okay so let's briefly
consider if I have something better than
just taking probably not okay he just
plays with the piece down or is there
something better castles it's probably
also good but I can also click the piece
oops sorry about this sonai g3 simply to
get rid of the Queen ham might play
Queen g2 or some some silly move maybe
ruki aight i just f king of one check
after the current rate it's a pretty
trivial win so okay so how to do it no
94 @ h5 for looks good in ok start with
this
just Queen f3m to get in Knight f6 and
that's quite nice being a piece up and
have the mating attack push-up g3s also
quite attempting movement depending on
what he's doing okay scheduling up the
exchange as well check
mhm is soon 95 maybe a month coming
I know I mean I'm just look up but still
want to try to not give him anything
unnecessary
check
laughs resigns yeah it's it's really a
bit surprising that then that you get an
IM play against you Bishop a six-year
but just just for for the noobs
businesses I mean new zoo Indian 101 you
must play nine th es absolutely the only
move to prevent the pin and to have this
kind of stuff available after after
Bishop g5 it's it's already very bad i
mean the computer does not agree at
first but maybe it takes some time and
absolutely don't care i mean what the
contest you cannot avoid i cannot allow
the pinion this is simply not good not
sure if i played played the right
punishment though a4 is very forceful
but not sure if it is the best
continuation okay the computer is
getting higher now giving white 0.7 0.8
him yeah I thought you would take okay
well this is not not exactly fantastic
for black the probably not not the
outright losing what this is just a
piece check I was a bit more afraid of
of King a commune g2 looks a bit more
tricky I was thinking maybe we should be
for rookie age Queenie to it this is
some not that clear actually check
okay check so probably the compounds to
go look into which is quite a remarkable
move check that's strong okay yeah look
III computer move that's not it's not
not super clear it's not super clear
plus one but not look like down Donald
whenever this this is when you know H
form given by the machine but this is
also when I am the plastid ria check ya
ain't just gave away even check more
material now this is 98 stuff this is
known since 1920s 1930s when the new
minion defense come into was really
introduced however if i look at this i
mean it's well known as mentioned that
you shouldn't allow it but it's not
clear that why this is down down right
winning or anything the computer is very
much on face it wants to play something
like this now i can now it gets a bit
higher for why I mean this is something
that you don't want to have but I'm not
sure how how terrible it is a problem is
terrible night g1 it's a very nice
suggestion by the comb so that after
this the queen is coming in quickly
interesting ok thanks for watching